[Musique]
Émilie Nicolas Michel David Chantal
Hébert un mot quand même en ce début de
panel sur cette année de guerre si
Vladimir Poutine
comptait sur des fissures et des
mésentent à l'ouest
à l'Occident il y aura
perdu son pari tour de table à pied
d'Émilie Nicolas bon c'est pas de quoi
l'avenir est fait mais on sait que
depuis un an ça tient assez bien là
ça tient effectivement c'est bien puis
un des éléments qu'on peut souligner on
pourrait parler de la question pendant
des heures mais un des éléments
peut-être à souligner ce qui avait
beaucoup de crainte au début de la
guerre pour la sécurité énergétique de
l'Europe notamment avec avec le gaz avec
le gaz russe qui qui compte pour
beaucoup d'improvisation et je pense que
c'est un des il y a un peu plus craint
bien sûr donc on peut parler mais je
voulais souligner cet élément-là dont on
a parlé peut-être moins dans les
derniers jours parce que en fait il y a
une adaptation absolument incroyable de
l'Europe au niveau des énergétique on
parle de 25% d'alimentation de la
production d'énergie solaire sur
quelques mois en Europe donc ça montre à
quel point lorsqu'on sent la crise
lorsque on ne peut plus dépendre du
reste la capacité d'adaptation quand
même et de coopération a été assez
spectaculaire à ce niveau là je pense
c'est un élément sur lequel on a moins
insisté peut-être dans les derniers
jours je pense que ça vaut la peine de
le rappeler Michel est Chantal monsieur
Legault et Trudeau aujourd'hui on dit
nous on après aller encore jusqu'au bout
accueillir des gens à participer
monsieur Trudeau a dit faut pas le
laisser gagner etc donc là dessus est-ce
que le Canada et et à lever et présent à
Michel et Chantal Michel oui le Canada
est présent c'est pas le plus le plus
militant si je peux dire il y avait des
chiffres dernièrement qui était qui ont
été publiés et je pense que sur les 40
pays qui ont fourni de l'aide à
l'Ukraine percapita ou en termes de PIB
j'aimerais dire le Canada est seulement
le 27e sur 40 alors on est là mais on
n'est pas les plus les plus aimés
mettons mais je veux juste dire un mot
sur la question que vous vous posez à
Émilie tantôt c'est vrai que il y a pas
eu de fissures qui est apparu et que la
Russie comptait sur sur la dépendance de
l'Europe à son énergie mais inversement
le temps misait beaucoup sur les
sanctions économiques contre la Russie
pour pour la mettre à genoux
littéralement ça se produit pas non plus
monsieur Poutine le PIB de la Russie a
reculé mais beaucoup moins qu'on avait
prévu de sorte que Poutine à tout
l'argent qui veut pour financer sa
guerre alors c'est pas c'est pas de
cette façon là qu'on va en venir à bout
alors la question se pose mais jusqu'où
faudrait-il aller dans les dans les
mesures militaires pour pour gagner
cette guerre là c'est que les Chinois
qu'on sait pas dans quelle mesure les
Chinois l'aide parce qu'achètent
beaucoup de son gaz et son pétrole
Chantal
trois choses on est loin du climat de la
première semaine il y a un an où il y
avait je pense que de façon presque
généralisée on se disait que l'Ukraine
n'allait pas tenir tellement longtemps
qu'on considère presque ce serait un
fait accompli une question de semaine on
n'est pas là du côté du Canada c'est
vrai qu'on est pas un des principaux
contributeurs à l'effort de guerre en
Ukraine on n'est pas non plus une grande
puissance militaire mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a quand même des
liens réels Justin Trudeau et sans
homologue et qui et qu'il dépense Justin
Trudeau du capital politique là où le
Canada en a encore un petit peu aux
États-Unis à la Maison Blanche à
l'Elysée pour pousser sur ceux qui
peuvent faire une différence la
troisième chose c'est en gros gros nuage
quelque part à l'horizon quand même et
c'est les développements politiques
électoraux aux États-Unis parce qu'on
rentre dans un cycle
présidentielle qui pourrait donner des
résultats imprévisibles les cadres
résultats pourraient franchement rendre
ce qu'on dit ce soir une constatation
optimiste par rapport à l'avenir oui
parce que il y a tout un courant aux
États-Unis en Europe aussi moi aux
États-Unis qui voudrait que monsieur
zenichi qui pousserait monsieur zenenska
négocier plus rapidement que tard etc
bon on va y revenir mais je tenais à
vous entendre là-dessus c'est quand même
la grosse actualité de la journée je
vous ramène au chemin waxam je vous fais
entendre réentendre ceux qui étaient
avec nous et qui était assis ici hier
l'ambassadeur des États-Unis qui est un
peu similaire qui joue un peu avec les
mots en tout cas je j'ai hâte de vous
entendre là-dessus et Monsieur Trudeau
aujourd'hui qui dit non non j'en ai
parlé puis je vais en reparler à
Monsieur Biden on écoute
maintenant
je peux vous assurer que dans mes
conversations directement avec le
président Biden il comprend à quel point
c'est une priorité pour le Canada et
c'est une priorité partagée de travail
ensemble pour assurer la sécurité de nos
frontières de notre frontière partagée
et ça va certainement être une
conversation que nous allons continuer
d'avoir avec l'administration américaine
y compris lors de la visite plus tard le
mois prochain
c'est un monsieur Trudeau de régler le
problème puis étant que les règles
mais voilà Chantal ce coin on l'a pas
entendu mais hier ajoutait moi je vous
confirme même pas que des négociations
il y a personne qui a parlé de ça au sud
la frontière et de toute façon ça
réglerait rien en gros je résume alors
j'entends on en est où
bon on parlait de politique américaine
et impératifs domestiques américains
c'est sûr que toute la question des
réfugiés et des immigrants que ce soit
régulier ou pas et un problème une épine
dans le pied de Joe Biden dont la
dernière
priorité c'est de sortir d'une rencontre
avec Justin Trudeau ou la manchette
serait Joe Biden va garder plus de
réfugiés réguliers ou un territoire
américain cela dit les ambassadeurs ne
sont pas tenus
par nous sont pas tenus de donner des
entrevues et quand il donne des
entrevues sont censés peser leurs mots
quand l'ambassadeur des États-Unis au
Canada dans le contexte actuel donne une
entrevue où il suggère presque que les
négociations sur l'ensemble des tiers
pays sur
peut-être que ça existe même pas c'est
quand même particulier et ça envoie un
message qui s'appelle nous ça nous
intéresse pas de parler de ce dossier
l'image Michel ouais ben il y a pas
vraiment de contradiction entre ce que
Monsieur Trudeau a dit sur la priorité à
accorder monsieur Trudeau a dit c'est la
priorité monsieur Biden connais qui
comprend très bien que c'est la priorité
du Canada mais il y a pas dit que
c'était la priorité des États-Unis et
l'ambassadeur nous du carrément qu'un
non seulement ne l'est pas alors pour ce
qui est des négociations moi je pense
que encore là on joue un peu sur les
mots c'est à dire des négociations
formelles sur l'entente de faire je
pense qu'il y en a pas monsieur Trudeau
dit à Monsieur Biden nous autres on a un
problème monsieur Biden on comprend que
vous avez un problème mais c'est pas
nous qui avons le régler alors
je retiens de tout ça là que quand
monsieur baiden va se présenter il faut
pas s'attendre à ce qui sortent et que
les deux premiers ministres annoncent
que il y a un règlement là-dessus claire
ment là c'est pas dans le dans le radar
sur le radar des Américains parce que ce
que Chantal dit est tout à fait juste si
il y avait une renégociation le résultat
net pour les Américains c'est qu'il
conserverait davantage le demandeur
d'asile de leur côté au nord Émilie
ça fait déjà plusieurs semaines qu'on
l'entendait le Premier ministre du moyen
qu'on avait dessiné du côté du fédéral
que pour la visite de Joe Biden en mars
l'entend sur les taper sûr à l'époque la
priorité ou quelque chose qu'on
attendait je pense que la seule raison
pour laquelle Justin Trudeau revient
là-dessus en disant oui on sait que
c'est une priorité partagée pour la
Canada etc c'est parce qu'il y a de la
pression politique de plus en plus forte
qui vient bien sûr de François degault
mais qui vient aussi de Pierre poillieve
donc ils essaient de se réajuster par
rapport à ça ça veut pas dire qu'il va
avoir plus de résultats prendre en masse
donc c'est un peu un exercice politique
délicat on va dire comme ça pour juste
un truc d'autre parce que si il dit que
c'est une vérité pour lui que c'est
vraiment important pour le Canada de
regarder sur et qui arrive au 1er mars
il fait juste essentiellement dire qu'il
y a pas de pouvoir par rapport à ses
relations avec les États-Unis on va tous
s'en rendre compte dans quelques
semaines donc c'est assez c'est assez
politiquement difficile l'autre question
je pense qu'on pourrait se poser par
rapport à ça c'est qu'est-ce que le
Canada peut faire pour les États-Unis
qui vous aurez un échange
essentiellement de service mutuel qui
pourrait
essentiellement motivé un peu les
Américains là-dessus et peut-être ça là
ça a l'air sans rien mais en fait la
pression que les États-Unis mettent
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois sur le
Canada pour régler la crise en Haïti
c'est en fait lié à la crise migratoire
parce que une des préoccupations des
Américains en Haïti c'est les beaux
people c'est les gens qui remontent des
résultats aux États-Unis donc ce n'est
pas un invitation du président américain
de que les canadiens viennent régler le
problème un des problèmes migratoires
des États-Unis à la source en fait donc
il y a peut-être des échanges de service
à ce niveau là ou à d'autres qui sont
possibles mais c'est clair que si Joe
Baden bougeait sur ce dossier là c'est
parce qu'elle Canada ferait quelque
chose probablement en retour qui
aiderait aussi des intérêts américains
et d'ailleurs monsieur blanken le dit
l'ambassadeur le dit à sa façon il faut
voir le problème globalement on peut pas
juste isoler un chemin demander nous pas
d'isoler le nous on regarde pas
seulement alors Chantal à court terme à
court terme pour Justin Trudeau il y a
pas beaucoup de pions à jouer là-dessus
là sur ce parce que la pression
politique monte c'est clair bon à court
terme la redistribution des demandeurs
d'asile qui passe par le chemin Roxane
avant enlever mais très court terme un
petit peu de pression mais ça dure pas
il y a pas des systèmes à toute épreuve
pensez le livre du prince des droits qui
dit on va en accueillir ils ont pas un
grand système d'accueil pour des
demandeurs d'asile et c'est vrai si on
pense au même tout bas ça sera de
continuer le pion qui reste c'est de
suspendre l'entendre sur des tiers pays
sur et à partir de ce moment-là on
redistribue autrement qu'en autobus les
demandeurs d'asile puisqu'ils se
présente à des postes frontières
réguliers mais effectivement la crainte
du Canada c'est que les chiffres vont
monter tout le monde va en avoir mais
tout le monde en avoir beaucoup s'inclus
de Québec à la colle bon ben mon
obsession la clarté là-dessus Michel et
Mélie quand Chantal dit si on déchire
parce que les gens disent qu'on déchire
l'entente on peut d'ailleurs on a un
préavis de 30 jours c'est terminé mais
si c'est terminé il rentre partout les
demandeurs d'asile ils peuvent faire
leur demande partout post régulier poste
régulier ressentir Michel et Mélie
qu'est-ce que ça règle Michel vous le
dites ça règle rien et sans pire le
problème c'est à dire que
partout ils peuvent ils peuvent entrer
tandis que là actuellement en vertu de
l'entente quand ils arrivent dans un
poste frontière officiel et qui sont des
des réfugiés qui arrivent des États-Unis
on leur dit écoutez vous êtes dans un
pays sûr en tout cas présumément sûr
restez vous allez rester là tandis qu'à
partir du moment on dit on reconnaît que
c'est pas un pays sûr bah là on les
laisse entrer que ça soit de façon
régulière ou irrégulière alors le flou
va simplement augmenter Emily conclusion
là-dessus
je pense qu'on est un peu le nez des
fois collé sur l'herbe quand on parle de
cette réalité là le Canada étant des
seuls pays à pas avoir de frontières
avec avec un des pays qui sont plus en
boîte développement que que nous on
était très isolé mais la réalité c'est
que la crise migratoire sont une réalité
est ennaseur qui va juste commencer à
augmenter ou 21e siècle j'ai
l'impression que c'est dans la semaine
qu'on est comme collé sur est-ce qu'on
peut régler à court terme le flux alors
que c'est quelque chose qui d'un point
de vue macro ne va qu'augmenter dans les
prochaines décennies avec la crise
climatique notamment donc j'ai
l'impression qu'on essaie de patcher
avec avec du du du doté quelque chose
qui va être un des grands enjeux du 21e
siècle et on est un peu dans le déni en
fait par rapport au fait que cette
réalité là il est là pour rester en tant
que sur les CRP sûr ou pas on traduit ce
que vous dites c'est ce que blinkin ne
dit en conférence de presse et presque
je suis pas en train de vous dire vous
dites que blinkin a dit mais c'est c'est
la réalité il voulait sensibiliser les
gens en disant oui je veux bien les amis
mais c'est quand même puis même si
Christian aime pas quand je dis ça c'est
quand même compliqué il y a des
pressions internationales il reste 4
minutes transfert en santé c'est parfait
on va voir le tableau l'Ontario là c'est
vraiment ils sont contents ils disent
écoutez nous on va se rendre 13,9 sur 10
ans ils ont signé la base qui augmente
pour tout le monde et leur entente
particulière à eux tour de table Michel
David
les accords tombe les uns après les
autres oui comme d'habitude je dirais
c'est un peu la même Patton si vous
passez l'expression qui à chaque
négociation et je m'attends à ce que les
les les quatre autres provinces sauf le
Québec et les deux territoires racines
rapidement pour ce qui est du Québec il
faut voir je regardais communiquer de
Santé Canada là qui annonçait l'entente
avec l'Ontario
c'est pas juste les gardes priorité et
le moment donné il est question du nom
de nouvelles négociations pour une
entente bilatérale de trois ans sur des
cibles précises des échéanciers ici là
on est plus simplement là dans les les
grandes priorités vagues ça ça commence
à ressembler à une reddition de compte
cette histoire-là alors ça je suis pas
certain que dans l'entente que le Québec
va signer on va retrouver quelque chose
comme ça Québec vas-y écouter on sait
déjà entendu sur le fait que c'est
asymétrique dans le cas du Québec on
n'est pas obligé de prendre les mêmes
choses alors j'ai hâte de voir mais je
serai surpris que Christian Dubé le
signe une entente qui aurait les mêmes
dispositions qu'on retrouve avec les
autres et là jusqu'au 21 mars Chantal
c'est le budget donc 20 mars
le transfert en santé va augmenter dans
tous les scénarios plus il y a de
l'argent moi ce que j'ai trouvé
intéressant
à observer dans ces entente là c'est que
c'était pas clair il y a de l'argent on
mange de l'augmentation du transfert une
cagnotte et c'était pas clair que serait
distribué au proratum plutôt que premier
rendu premier service ou celui qui signe
prend l'argent et jusqu'à présent on a
l'air de respecter le parc Capitole donc
la part du Québec correspondant à son
poids démographique d'autre part les
libéraux ont commencé l'idée du
traitement symétrique du Québec en santé
Steven un peu de continuer et juste
intrudo par la suite je serais pas
étonné que l'entente avec le Québec soit
asymétrique et qu'on discute en fonction
de cette asymétrie oui déjà même ce
Trudeau aujourd'hui a dit les données du
Québec sont peut-être plus avancés et
mais ce qui peut laisser présager
effectivement un autre sorte d'entente
Émilie
c'est un peu ça je pense la stratégie de
du gouvernement fédéral depuis le début
au niveau de même de la manière on est
arrivé à ce type d'entendre là
asymétrique il y avait les provinces qui
faisaient quand même pression depuis
très longtemps pour avoir des rencontres
plus longues avec les premiers ministres
avant des rencontres plutôt pour pouvoir
négocier en bloc mais je pense que le
fait que essentiellement juste un
Trudeau a refusé de personnes si ça
c'est à dire au début de février avec
avec les premiers ministres provinciaux
pendant quoi deux trois heures seulement
pour arriver ensuite à négocier ça
vraiment à la carte qu'on voit ça en
fait c'est le fruit de cette stratégie
là au niveau de la négociation politique
qui fait que en fait chacun essaie d'y
trouver son compte puis l'objectif bien
sûr c'était de régler ça avant la saison
budgétaire très rapidement donc c'est
sûr qu'il va avoir probablement un peu
comme tout le monde le dit déjà quelque
chose d'assez différent qui va arriver
pour le Québec mais si ce modèle est
possible c'est justement à côté de
négociation que le gouvernement fédérale
a mis en place pour pour essentiellement
protéger ses propres intérêt à lui ce
n'est pas un complot monsieur faitgaben
j'ai pas le temps de vous de me faire
l'autre sujet a été blanchi a été
blanchi par la commissaire à l'éthique à
Québec alors je le dis c'est dit on en
reparlera yes une dernière cause sur les
les faisans à entendre merci beaucoup
vous trois merci à bientôt au revoir
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI